Jean-Sébastien Cloutier
s'est rendu sur place
il y a quelques jours.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La journée était belle
à Oujé-Bougoumou.
Un matin frais, qui rappelle
que l'automne est précoce
au 50e parallèle. Le village,
fondé il y a 30 ans, est le plus
récent des neufs villages cris
du Nord du Québec.
Il y a 4 ans, ici, 42 résidents
avaient voté aux élections
provinciales, soit 9 % seulement
des électeurs inscrits.
JONATHAN G. SAGANASH, propri.
Eenou Eeyou Construction
- Traditionnellement
à'a'automne, les Cris d'Eeyou
Eetchee sont en forêt
à la chasse à l'orignal.
- Les Cris ont aussi leur propre
Jonathan Saganash. Mais il ira
voter le 3 octobre, les besoins
sont trop nombreux.
Au village, son entreprise
construit un centre de formation
professionnelle, oùeses métiers
comme la charpenterie seront
enseignés. Dans Ungava, 45 % de
lala population n'a aucun diplô.
- Ça va aider au développement
de la communauté directement.
Souvent les gens vont aller
à l'extérieur, vont avoir
de la misère à revenir,
parce que justement,
dû au manque de maison.
- La pénurie de logement est
un autre problème dans
les communautés cries
et inuites. À Oujé-Bougoumou,
des familles sont sur une liste
d'attente depuis des années.
CURTIS BOSUM, chef de la Nation
crie d'Oujé-Bougoumou
- Aujourd'hui, tu vois des
familles qui vivent encore
trois, quatre familles dans
la même maison, puis on veut
essayer de régler cette
situation. On est en crise
- Seule candidate à avoir
quelques pancartes au village,
Maïté Labrecque-Saganash, de
Québec solidaire, pretet d'agir.
MAÏTÉE LABRECQUE-SAGANASH
candidate, Québec solidaire
- On prévoit 1000 logements
pour le Nord.
- Active au sein de plusieurs
organismes locaux et fille de
l'ancien député fédéral Roméo
Saganash, elle espère devenir
la preèère femme autochtone
élue à l'Assemblée Nationale.
- Pour moi, c'est important
de faire campagne où est-ce que
les candidats font jamais
campagne en fait, soit dans
les communautés autochtones.
- Est-ce que la clé de votre
victoire serait là?
- Je pense que oui.
- Le caquiste Denis Lamothe
avait été élu par 46 voix
seulement dans Ungava en 2018,
devant le PartQuQuébécois.
C'est en majorité la population
des villes de Chibougamau
et de Chapais qui avaient voté
pour l. . Et qui pourraient bien
le faire réélire.
- Le gouvernement présent,
il fait mon affaire...
J'ai trouvé qu'il a fait
un bon travail.
- Je trouve qu'il a géré
la crise de la façon
que ça devait être géré.
DENIS LAMOTHE, candidat CAQ
- Vraiment au niveau
des infrastrucreres,
que ce soit scolaires,
sportives, que ce soit
au Nunavik, que ce soit
sur le territoire cri,
je pense que qu'un moment donné,
notre bilan est bon.
- Sa priorité s'il est réélu :
attirer plus de résidents.
- Il y a des endroits
stratégiques où est-ce qu'il y a
des emplois avec Hydro-Québec,
les mines. On aimerait nous
autres que less viennent
s'installer chez-nous,
qu'ils demeurent chez-nous.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais chez les Premières
Nations, la CAQ ne semble pas
favorite. À Oujé-Bougoumou,
cette promesse de François
Legault a été mal accueillie.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
chef Coalition avenir Québec
- Je vais demander
à Hydro-Québec de regarder
la possibilité de construire
des nouveaux barrages.
- On n'a pas eu de consultation,
on n'a pas été...
- Ça a été mal reçu?
- Bien moi je l'ai vu comme
un... comme un "oups!"
♪ ♪ ♪
- Au Musée du village,
qui a gagné un prix pour son
architecture, on rencontre
Katie Shecapio la directrice.
À propos des barrages, elle
cite un aîné de la communauté :
KATHY SHECAPIO, directrice,
Inst. cult. cri Aanischaaukamikw
- La terre, c'est comme le corps
humain : t'affectes "one area,"
nécessairement t'impactes
tout le systè..
- Autre frustration; cette
question récurntnte du racisme
systémique que la CAQ
ne reconnait pas.
- De dire  p pour moi, c'est
de me faire dire que les
expériences que j'ai vécues,
le prolalage, me faire arrêter
dans la rue : "t'es-tu rouge?"
Par un système d'éducation qui a
appris à ces gens-là à nous
parler comme ça, comme si on
n'était moins que humains.
Il y a du travail à faire
là-dessus.
- Le candidat libéral est Inuk
et a été maire de Kuujjuak
pendant 6 ans.
Les 14 communautés du Nunavik
sont accessibles par avion
seulement, la sécurité
alimentaire de son peuple est
une priorité.
TUNU NAPARTUK,
candidat, PLQ, Ungava
- Notre coût de vie est énorme.
Ça peut coûter deux, trois isis
plus cher que de vivre
dans le Sud, mais avec le taux
d'inflation qui complique notre
qualité de vie, c'est enrere
beaucoup plus difficile.
- Et dans le Grand Nord aussi,
la promesse de nouveaux barrages
semble mal reçue.
- Non on en veut pas!
Ça c'est sûr et certain.
- Inuits et Crisururont donc
un gros rôle à jouer dans
les résultats d'Ungava.
Mais voteront-ils?
(cri)
Les émissions radiophoniques de
Clarence Snowboy sont diffusées
dans tous les villages cris.
"Personne ne me parle des
élections, dit-il, je n'ai même
pas eu de questions
sur les dates du vote."
- Je trouve qu'il y a un manque.
- "Malheureusement, dit le chef
Bosu l les Premières Nations,
encore une fois, ont été quasi
absentes des discours
des chefs."
- - Ils veulent développer le Nd
du Québec et nous vivons dans
le Nord du Québec.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La circonscription d'Ungava
couvre pourtant la moitié de la
superficie de toute la province.